Mr President ladies and gentlemen
I very much thank you for the invitation
here
it is such a pleasure
to be here in Buenos Aires in Argentina
it is a country of breathtaking Beauty
if you look at the whole country
from the Amazon to down to the peaks of
the ants to the glaciers of Patagonia
and indeed today I had the pleasure to
see a bit more of the city what a
fantastic City you have here so it's
good to be here many thanks for having
invited me
[Applause]
there is so much that we argentinians
and Europeans have in common
we share indeed deep historical and
cultural ties
we are the oldest of friends
in many cases We Are Family
we uphold common values
we share Mutual interests
including a passion for football
and I must admit that as president of
the European commission I of course
supported France
in the FIFA World Cup final but
Argentina's performance was just
spectacular so congratulations and
well-deserved victory
we have always been natural partners and
Friends
and let me borrow the words of Raul
alfonsin your first modern democratic
president 40 years ago now he was in
Strasbourg and he was speaking to the
European Parliament
and he was there just a few months after
winning the historic elections of 1983
said and I quote
Europe seems so diverse but is also so
United
Latin America seems so United
but is also so diverse
we are brought together by the same
values the same Democratic convictions
so we are bound to work together
end of quote
and this was true 40 years ago
when both Argentina
and Southern European countries
we're moving from dictatorship
to democracies and it is still true
today
we are brought together by the same
values we share the same Democratic
conviction
and our shared Foundation is indeed
robust
after 40 Years of cooperation nearly
half of all foreign direct investment
into Argentina comes from the European
Union
we are your third largest trading
partner and European companies are
responsible for almost 300 000 000 jobs
here in Argentina
starts with the financial services via
chemicals via pharmaceutical industry
and of course the automotive
Manufacturing
but there is so much more we can do
together
this potential of our friendship
is so much bigger
today our economic agendas if you look
at them overlap like never before for
example on clean energy
on raw materials on digital
infrastructure
so I think it is time that we launch a
new era of cooperation between old
friends
and that is the reason why I'm here
today
and I see two main Avenues
for Argentina and for Europe to grow
closer
first indeed we have the historic
opportunity to finally push the EU
Microsoft agreement across the finish
line
I am committed to include conclude this
Marcus who agreement as soon as possible
and I think let it let us get it done
before the end of the year that should
be our common goal
the EU Marcus who agreement is the
largest and the most ambitious trade
deal both the European Union and Marcus
sewer have ever negotiated
it would bring together two of the
world's largest trading blocks with a
combined population
of over 700 million consumers
the potential of economic progress is
immense
let me give you an example
a few few weeks ago I was in South Korea
and there I saw the impressive positive
impact of the trade real we have closed
and concluded
in a little over a decade
EU trade with Korea has grown by 110
percent
so this is what happens when you give
people and business the opportunity to
work across borders trade increases
exponentially the economy flourishes and
the most important people benefit so
let's do it
and this is why Marcus Who and the
European Union
should address the final outstanding
issues still this year and I very much
count on Argentina as the current chair
of marcosua to do its fair share too
but beyond trade
there is so much more potential to our
friendship
you have
so many
bright
passionate young people
your education system ranks the highest
in Latin America
higher than most G20 Nations
you both universities that rank among
the best in the world
like the Instituto balcero or the
universita de Buenos Aires which
produced actually five Nobel Prize
laureates you can be so proud of it
[Applause]
or take your tech companies 20 of the
unicorns corns in Latin America are from
Argentina 20 percent
innovators like globent and mercado
Libre
or look at your Argentine company that
produces radioisotopes for cancer
treatment in European hospitals that
saves lives
but as entrepreneurs everywhere
Argentinian entrepreneurs and problem
solvers need investment
and this is where Europe
can truly make a difference
and investment needs a predictable and
conducive environment
that's where Argentina can make a
difference
back to the investment let me give you
two examples
clean energy and raw materials just to
see and to show what we can do together
as you might know Europe is committed to
be the first climate neutral continent
by 2050.
but to succeed in this journey
Europe will need massive supplies of
renewable energy
your country has all it takes
to become a renewable energy Powerhouse
in large parts of your beautiful country
in the large plateau of the South
you can only hear one sound
and this is the sound of the wind
running undisturbed
you have harvested this natural resource
that is there in abundance
in the last four years Argentina has
increased its wind power by the factor
of 20.
the extraordinary Patagonian winds are a
blessing of nature
if you create the right infrastructure
for electricity and green hydrogen
they can power Argentina and the world
and Europe stands ready to invest
together we can build a stable and
reliable partnership
so in the end if we think it's ruined if
we make it happen
Renewables from Argentina would not only
bring clean and sustainable energy to
the world
but also well-paying jobs and revenues
to Argentina let's embark on that
journey together
let me give you another example
unless you
some call it the white gold for
electrification of our economies
you have among the world's largest
reserves of lithium
and you have a robust manufacturing
sector including four vehicles
let me just give you two figures
two years ago
of 25 Vehicles sold globally
one was an electric vehicle
today
only two years later
of five Vehicles sold globally one was
an electric vehicle
so the demand for electric vehicles is
Sky rocketing
and this is just the beginning
because don't forget no battery without
lithium
and here too Argentina can become a
major partner for Europe
together we're able to build resilient
Supply chains for batteries
and I think important is
different through today
that the added value stays here in
Argentina
in other words
[Applause]
in other words together we will develop
value chains that go beyond only
extraction that's the case today
but if you go beyond that this creates
jobs and opportunities along the whole
value chain in Argentina
and to that end I am happy that we
signed today a memorandum of
understanding for raw materials this is
a great step forward and we will both
benefit from it
so far the two examples of lithium and
renewable energy but you can add
countless other examples that follow the
same pattern
it is precisely to support this kind of
investment I've just described
that we have created our global gateway
investment plan
there you see the sign
global gateway
has already launched 90 project
worldwide this year
and for Latin America and the Caribbean
I am pleased to announce that we are
almost doubling
our investment for the projects in this
region
European Union alone will make 10
billion euros available
and this will be complemented by the
contribution by Our member states and of
course by the contribution of the
private investment sector
but it is not only about the money
it is also about the method
investments from elsewhere often come
with strings attached
the famous footnotes
or leads to harmful dependencies
our approach is different
what you see is what you get the project
are tailored to local realities
but they share the same principles
and the first one is sustainability
we want to guarantee the highest
environmental standards
we want that local community's benefit
and we want to ensure Financial
transparency
which is so essential for the
predictability that investors need
global gateway is bringing together
companies financial institutions public
and private investors and all the
relevant sectors so global gateway can
be the Boost that Argentina's high value
industry needs
our teams already identify projects on
the ground so let's get to work and
let's get it done together
ladies and gentlemen
let me raise a final point
and Mr President at the very beginning
you were mentioning the geopolitical
tensions
where experiences is experiencing
and in a time of geopolitical tensions
we want our like-minded Latin American
friends
to be by our side
we should not forget that for decades
both
Europe and Latin America have been an
integral part
of building a world order based on rules
with the United Nations system
at its core
the very first few words of the United
Nations Charter
proclaim the determination of the
peoples of the United Nations
to save succeeding Generations from the
scourge of War
unfortunately we all know
War
and conflict have not been eliminated
from our planet
when Russia
a nuclear-armed permanent member of the
U.N security Council
send it thanks over the borders of
Ukraine last year
to conquer its Sovereign neighbor
this was simply a war of choice
and it was a direct strike
on our International order
and the U.N Charter that we all depend
on
since the beginning of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine
I have been in Keith several times
I've been in butcher
right after the liberation of butcher
I saw the mass Graves
I saw the body bags lined up
I saw the scars
from missiles
sent to terrorize civilians
destroying homes
hospitals
Schools kindergarten
of course we want peace
and no one more than the ukrainians
want peace
but it must be a just
it must be a just and Lasting peace that
upholds the principles of the UN Charter
enshrined in the U.N Charter is for
example the principle of sovereignty
and territorial Integrity for each and
every country on this globe
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and of course we want
a just peace that upholds the ukrainians
people's right to be the masters of
their own future
president zielinski has come forward
with a peace formula
everyone
of his 10 points in his 10 point peace
formula
is based on the principles of the U.N
Charter and deducted from U.N
resolutions
and he has invited the countries around
the world
to join in and build on that peace
formula
I want to thank Argentina
for your unwavering and steadforced
support in the multilateral Forum that
we have in the United Nations you voted
on every single resolution concerning
this topic with us
and we really thank you for that clear
commitment
clear standing we will not forget that
the people of Ukraine
I think that our starting point for
peace therefore should be the
rules-based order
because the people of Ukraine deserve an
end to their suffering
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
Europe wants to launch a new partnership
with Argentina
a partnership that puts people
and their passion for Innovation first
I've just been to the exhibition it's
fascinating to see the young people
there and if you haven't been there
please go there and have a look it's
amazing to see The Innovation that is in
that room the nature-based solution
these young people have found the
passion with which they have developed
their project and have been presenting
it to me we want a partnership that puts
these people in the first place we want
a partnership of democracies standing
together we want a partnership of shared
prosperity
in other words we want a new beginning
for Old Friends many things
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much
[Applause]